Defense Secretary Pete Hoekstra's
tattoos are back in the news. A few
months ago I discussed his Crusader
tattoos, but now it's his tattoo of an
Arabic word, kaffir, that is apparently
creating much outrage amongst Muslims.
Before proceeding, let's first define
the word kaffir, for it is indeed an
important though much misunderstood
word, and therefore something that you,
an intelligent person as evidenced by
the fact that you're watching this
video, should be aware of. The word
kaffir, singular form kuffar or kuffara
plural, is almost entirely known by its
connotations, all of which are negative,
rather than its denotation or literal
meaning. The triliteral root word
kuffara and its derivatives in old
pre-Islamic Arabic literally meant to
cover or hide something. In Islamic
usage, a kaffir came to mean someone
who, after being invited or exposed to
the truths of Islam, still rejects them,
still covers them up or hides them.
Hence today a kaffir is someone who
rejects Islam or in modern parlance, a
non-Muslim. And yet translating the word
to non-Muslim or unbeliever, as almost
every modern English language Quran
does, completely misses the
all-important and decidedly negative
connotations associated with the word.
This is incidentally why older English
translations rendered the word kaffir as
infidel, as I often do. Although still
an imperfect translation, it sought to
capture the pejorative sense of the
Arabic with one English word.
To Muslim ears, kaffir singular and
kuffar plural are are virtually
synonymous with evildoers and enemies.
In fact, virtually every vile human
characteristic and not a few connected
to animals is associated with the word
kaffir. As usual, let us turn to the
Quran. It refers to kuffar as the worst
of beasts, as cattle, and just as dumb.
Kuffar are inherently guilty, unjust,
criminal-like. They are the sworn
enemies of Muslims and Islam. They are
disliked and accursed by Allah. The
Islamic deity is himself their declared
enemy, who requires that terror be cast
into their hearts.
See this video's description for the
verses that correspond with these
unflattering characteristics.
Again, this is how the Quran describes
all non-Muslims, even if they have never
once spoken against or harmed Islam.
Unsurprisingly then, Islamic law
mandates hostility for the kuffar,
unremitting jihad with all the death and
destruction that has always accompanied
it, at least when Muhammad's followers
are strong. When they're weak, however,
and in need of biding time for a more
opportune moment, deception of and
friendly gestures to the kaffir,
taqiyya, are permitted. Thus, according
to Quran 9:5, a Muslim must kill those
who reject Islam. Quote, "Wherever you
find them, seize them, besiege them, and
make ready to ambush them."
If that sounds familiar, perhaps it's
because the Muslim ambassador of
Barbary, North Africa, paraphrased this
verse when explaining to Thomas
Jefferson and John Adams why his muscle
why his Muslim countrymen were raiding
American vessels and killing and
enslaving their kaffir sailors. As
Jefferson wrote in a letter to Congress
in 1786, quote, "The ambassador answered
us that it was founded on the laws of
their prophet, that it was written in
their Quran, that it was their right and
duty to make war upon them, non-Muslims,
kuffar, wherever they could be found,
and to make slaves of all they could
take as prisoners."
But what about Ahl al-Kitab, the
so-called people of the book, a phrase
the Quran sometimes applies to Jews and
Christians? Are they kuffar or not?
Although Islam's apologists regularly
argue for the latter, Ahl al-Kitab,
while marginally better, is ultimately a
subcategory of kaffir. The Quran itself
makes this abundantly clear. For
example, it says that those who believe
in the Trinity, or who believe that
Christ is the son of God, two things all
Christians believe, have committed kufr,
meaning they are kuffar. See Quran 5:72
and 73.
Incidentally, because the kuffar are
essentially animal-like subhumans in
comparison to Muslims, Sharia bans the
execution of Muslims for any and all
crimes, including murder, that Muslims
may commit against non-Muslims, in
keeping with Muhammad's own words,
quote, "Let no Muslim be killed on
account of a kaffir," as recorded in
Sahih Bukhari and other canonical
collections.
This teaching is constantly invoked in
the Muslim world, though people in the
West seldom hear of it, meaning Western
media seldom report on it. For example,
several Muslim scholars and institutes
argued back in 2008 that a convicted
Muslim murderer should not be executed
because his victim, John Granville, an
American diplomat, was a kaffir, and
therefore their lives could not be
treated as equal. In an Arabic language
statement titled, quote, "Let no Muslim
be killed on account of a kaffir," which
is verbatim from Muhammad, the
legitimate League of Scholars and
Preachers in Sudan, an influential body
of Muslim clerics, began their fatwa by
asserting that, quote, "Allah has
honored human beings over creation and
multiplied the Muslims' honor over the
kaffirs, because Islam elevates and
nothing is elevated above it. The value
of the blood of Muslims is equal, or
should be, to one another, but not so
the value of the blood of others,
meaning kuffar."
Similarly, during a videotape sermon,
Egyptian cleric Samir Hashish once
explained, quote, "The prophet said,
'Let no Muslim be killed on account of a
kaffir.'" Again, that's the hadith of
what Muhammad said. And he continues,
the cleric, "Why? Because their blood is
not equal. The blood of the Muslim is
superior. Call it racism or whatever you
want, but of course the blood of the
Muslim is superior. This is not open to
debate. Arabic language link in the
description to what that uh cleric said,
though it may soon be taken down as
often happens. Let's now return to Pete
Hoekstra and see what all the hubbub is
about. Muslims, according to numerous
media reports, are simply outraged that
he dared tattoo the word kaffir on his
arm. But why? That is precisely what he
is according to Islam's own definitions
and usage. As we saw, all non-Muslims
are by default kuffar. That is to say,
all non-Muslims are the worst of beasts,
cattle, dumb, guilty, unjust, criminal,
sworn enemies of Islam, and accursed of
Allah, to quote the Quran.
The problem is ultimately one of
provenance. A highly offensive word,
kaffir is only meant to be used
disparagingly by Muslims to describe
non-Muslims. When a non-Muslim willingly
appropriates it, however, and wears it
as a tattoo no less, that is, as a badge
of honor, then it becomes the ultimate
act of defiance against Islam. It
becomes a statement. Yes, not only am I
a non-Muslim, but I'm all the ugly
things you Muslims say about us and
more. What of it? In short, Muslim anger
has nothing to do with Pete Hoekstra
being a kaffir, which Islam makes him to
be, and everything to do with him being
defiantly proud of it.